et
[Musique]
il ya une sorte d'unanimité quand même
contre les shadoks on est bien obligé de
le reconnaître mais là il ya un sujet
qui revient très souvent et nous sommes
obligés de consacrer deux séquences à ce
que réclament certains spectateurs
je vous lire une lettre qu'il faut faire
comprendre tout de suite de quoi il
s'agit cette lettre vient de du
lieutenant-colonel je sais pas on dilue
du lieutenant ou de monsieur le
lieutenant-colonel je sais pas je
m'excuse mans mon lieutenant luttant
colonel la bonde 20 bis avenue des
fleurs à nice monsieur le directeur
attention je m'excuse j'ai pas pris ma
voix de militaires mais suit le
directeur en réponse à la question posée
voulez-vous les bandes dessinées au nom
de ma famille je réponds catégoriquement
non parce que ces dessins sont horribles
à voir ils sont incohérents les shadoks
n'ont ni queue ni tête
ce qui est faux mon colonel ils ont des
vilaines tête et des vilaines que mais
ils ont à la fois des queues et des
têtes en faire un feuilleton ne rime à
rien puisqu'on ne peut rien à retenir
enfin le culte de la laideur n'est pas
encouragé ses frais il faut dire
d'ailleurs que dans l'armée vous faites
un maximum pour ça mais voyez ce qu'on
peut retirer de cette plate c'est que
vous trouvez le chat d'oc l'est vous ne
trouvez pas beau pour qu'il soit bon
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire il
faudrait plonger dans les histoires de
l'arrêt et essayer d'embellir les
shadoks c'est ce que nous avons fait
mais bien sûr pour évoquer une histoire
de l'art avec les shadoks il nous faut
plusieurs séquences alors notre première
séquence d'aujourd'hui s'intéressera
plus particulièrement
à l'antiquité et ira de l'antiquité
jusqu'à jusqu'à la guerre de 14 par
exemple on connaît lé chat d'oc sous
forme de hiéroglyphes
si un détail
[Musique]
shadoks inspiré par la crête sur une
amphore shadoks ramsès
d'où découlent directement le chat date
pyramidale shadow keller détails du
bouclier san roque centurion ingrat des
shader x cocorico
le premier château de gaulle ou cocorico
shadoks en boîte ou attaches à note
contenant un château
voici maintenant une expédition shadoks
en bateau qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
le chat d'oc découvrant l'amérique voici
la rencontre avec les animaux j'adopte
boulot pour un hommage à henri iv
shadoks découvrant la prime risque que
ça change quand son frère d'ailleurs
jallet prend siècle shadoks sans culotte
est en colère on en à l'hostie et tout
s'arrange
voici le shabak empire
ensuite le chat d'oc de la grande guerre
ou chat d'oc en taxi de la main
[Musique]